hello and welcome to zero play inertial
mass a cascade that cascade right now
let's see no info okay um well well why
did I play night of six it's not my
usual move okay let's play sound and
solid him get a Catalan probably know
this is the ratty system I don't have a
great recipe against that to be
perfectly honest well I normally only
play this line with with d5 d6 in in
blitz not so much in in serious over the
board games but it's already I'm
struggling ok let's shoot for that and
we plan something on before
use that slightly weakened be four
square well slightly bigger is wrong is
severely weakened but it's not not
terrible for white
now my next moves are b6 and Bishop e7
now what doesn't have that many plans
available here what you can't rise
something like a form it's one reason by
a plate night before efore no it's not
possible anymore um okay can also try to
play a queen be one Queen be too yeah or
this one okay so here's fear terror with
the Queen I was thinking that c5 should
be okay for me at least oh wait wait
might take it sorry he might take it
I'm talking about the night might take
the night on before and it slightly
uncomfortable at least hmm okay yeah but
okay if he takes it I should have some
play with with my bishops them just when
Drew k 1 okay d for wasn't possible
unfortunately
okay let's do this then I can move my
knight that's useful uh-huh okay didn't
think about this move at all interesting
okay now I'm ready for d for that was
one idea anyway and after G fried looks
like a logical option after his week in
this King side because and the idea okay
dear 49 to 63 I just play screen shakes
I guess and weight deform and how does
that work d 496 dc-3 DC 398 Exxon be 2
rupee one loop t8 which takes him that's
not actually doing that much ok
no I'm threatening default the only
thing as it took a lot of time
I would still like to play that d for
move but that doesn't seem to work
sometimes you can sack up on there why
not but them doesn't seem to work here
but I don't see any problem with just
playing solid moves in my structures
completely is totally sound and why
doesn't have any particularly
threatening ideas please I don't see any
I kill you in 20 g 6 nothing wrong with
it but also f6 as possible our main
danger is the time situation
well that's unsound but then let's see
what he tries maybe you will second f6
that's entirely incorrect but he might
feel tempted by the time and when why
this was if you place just Bishop t2 or
Bishop you want I just takes you five so
you will probably play Bishop f6 and see
if we can get something going down nope
didn't do it so I'm just winning this
this pawn time morning okay I'm I'm
trying to play actively here returning a
pawn for damage of his pawn structure
here check let's see now I 906 the idea
trying to play as actively as possible
here with the time situation that's
probably not a not a bad idea 95 is also
move but this make sense going for Queen
f3 maybe 194 maybe 90 forces plan
princess seven even Air Force as
possible no one was not doing it
this looks good to check g5 and have a
look at them f5 and so on it looks quite
decent configure the Queen but then
that's Queen two is six a damn check
bloody time right back rank is not good
check in 11 seconds no I must be happy
with the draw if he if he allows it
bloody back cranky check I've got three
seconds here check check black forfeits
on time yeah that's how you win games
miss Turkish cotton yeah anyway yeah it
spent too much time there i mean why
this mitis of course just busted him but
here I've got one minute and I should
just speed just get more speed on him
and not playing so many sophisticated
musiah problem okay I'm still okay what
took so long this took Stu quite long
yeah it's just very complicated yeah
with d 4 and so on I can just play
something like this and i'm just a pawn
up and this is probably what I should do
not place so complicated stuff with the
with little time and check that it's
might it might might have been okay but
it doesn't just it's not very practical
yeah i think the position is very equal
ish until you play g5 which is suicidal
after before black wins but yeah as I
said simple player would have been would
have been better than the fancy d4 move
just 90 f six cent and I'm upon up for
no compensation whatsoever yeah yeah
I've need to complicate it sometimes and
situation where it's not necessary yeah
I take a page out of order gasps books
play play quick play simple okay thanks
watching